uh there is a fascinating and disturbing
exclusive story from mother jones and
the story is that fox news propagandist
tucker carlson's recent pro-putin
propaganda is so pleasing to putin it's
so pleasing to russia
that the kremlin wrote a memo which
mother jones has obtained
and the memo is the kremlin directing
russian media to regularly feature
tucker carlson's content now
in a in a sense this is perfectly
logical we've been covering for two
weeks now tucker carlson sort of soft
pro putin apologia and casting doubt on
ukraine and its leader um
in in ways that are slightly more subtle
than just coming out and saying putin's
great right i mean that's not what
tucker is doing
but it's still propaganda so useful to
the kremlin that the kremlin has noticed
and is saying let's regularly translate
and use tucker carlson clips on russian
state media when the enemy sees you as a
sort of collaborator in a sense
you should really step back
and think about what it is that you were
putting out there let's take a look at a
little bit of this memo
again this is a great story great
investigative work by david korn and
mother jones leaked kremlin memo to
russian media it is quote essential to
feature tucker carlson the russian
government has pressed outlets to
highlight the fox host's putin helping
broadcasts uh there's even a quote from
the
um
from the memo
which says it is essential to use as
much as possible fragments of broadcasts
of the popular fox news host tucker
carlson who sharply criticizes the
actions of the united states and nato
their negative role in unleashing the
conflict in ukraine and the defiantly
provocative behavior from the leadership
of the western countries and nato
towards the russian federation and
towards president putin personally this
is a 12-page document written in russian
it sums up carlson's position russia is
only protecting its interests and
security the memo even includes a quote
from tucker and how would the u.s behave
if such a situation developed in
neighboring mexico or canada now what's
missing from that analysis as we've
talked about before
uh is actually different it's been wait
a second for these people that are doing
the soft putin apologia
how would they suggest or imagine the us
would react
if mexico or canada started doing what
russia is doing and i think it's really
important not to get sucked into some of
what we sometimes call these
philosophical black holes or uh
rhetorical propaganda devices
imagine because
go back to how putin justified the start
of this invasion
putin's entire premise was listen i mean
in crimea back in 2014 more recently
when two weeks ago at the start of this
putin recognized the independence of the
donetsk and luhansk regions imagine
if mexico said i don't know we're
sitting here on the border to the u.s
we're in mexico and we're looking over
at arizona and we're looking at
california and we're looking at texas
we see a lot of people who
look like us you know mexican americans
we hear a lot of people who speak our
language spanish
and
some of them
allegedly
want to be part of mexico so we
recognize the independence of those
areas i don't know border towns pick a
border town we recognize the
independence of juarez or whatever um
and you know just because we don't feel
that the mexican americans are being
treated that well
we're going to send some tanks over as
an example so the idea here of if
we were
russia
and you uh mexico and canada
did what ukraine is doing how would we
react but it completely ignores the
similar thought experiment which you
could say is valid or not because the
circumstances in russia and ukraine are
different anyway but it ignores the
analogous situation of well what if the
u.s were ukraine
and canada and or mexico started
behaving like putin has been in russia
that one they don't want to talk about
so needless to say
tucker carlson's show
has become
the sort of thing you would kind of
expect to see on what i would call soft
russian state media
the the stuff that's not like overtly
the uh dictates of the kremlin but doing
apologia for it you see a lot of folks
associated with the left although it's
not really clear why they're still
associated with the left glen greenwald
as an example jimmy dore and others um
uh increasingly appearing with tucker
carlson and doing what what sort of
appears to be a bipartisan apologia when
really what we're talking about here is
these are angry contrarian grifters
tucker carlson i don't even know if he
believes any of this stuff tucker
carlton's expertise is weaponizing the
ignorance of his audience with
contrarian reactionary rhetoric made to
make people afraid or feel like they're
questioning the official narrative in a
way that makes sense and of course
questioning the official narrative is a
beautiful thing it's called epistemology
critical thinking media literacy
evaluating why we believe the things we
believe but these folks have really
become the the prototypical example of
useful idiots now when i say useful
idiot i'm not i don't want to use the
term idiot as a pejorative
useful idiot as a as a term has a very
specific meaning which is
a useful idiot is someone
who ends up propagandizing for a cause
without fully comprehending the causes
goals
or that they are even necessarily doing
it
and then they end up being cynically
used by the leaders of the cause i mean
but by the definition of useful idiot
it is impossible to argue that tucker
carlson is not a useful idiot here in
this case tucker
is uh propagandizing for putin whether
he realizes it or not that's that's the
beauty of the term he doesn't matter he
may not realize it he may just be saying
what's gonna fire up my audience the
same way at one point it was claiming
the fbi did the january sixth riots did
does tucker really believe that i don't
know but he's he's targeting his
audience for ratings and to kind of keep
this persona of i'll tell you what's
really going on
and that propagandizing for russia is
being cynically used by the kremlin
which we now know because of this memo
and i don't know if the right wingers
who watch tucker find themselves in a
pickle you know they either you either
stand by tucker and you end up sort of
softly supporting putin or you have to
reject the guy
that you believed was giving you the
truth all along so
quite the cognitive dissonance that they
must be experiencing and uh in fact i
the next segment is going to be
about exactly the type of uh pro putin
conspiratorial apologia that we've been
seeing from tucker carlson
one of our longtime sponsors is monk
pack giving you 20
off monk packs keto nut and seed bars
which taste just like your favorite
sweet snacks
but without the guilt because they have
only one gram of sugar two to three net
carbs and 150 calories a great snack if
you're doing keto if you're doing low
carb and if you just want a low sugar
snack i love the monk pack nut and seed
bars great balance of sweet and salty
satisfyingly crunchy soft and chewy
because i like these so much i use monk
packs subscription feature sends them
straight to my house on a regular basis
and saves me ten percent if you don't
love monk pack as much as i do they will
refund you all your money i think
there's a really good chance monk pack
nut and seed bars become your favorite
go-to snack
monk pack is giving you 20 off your
first order go to monkpack.com and enter
the code pacman at checkout